allahuakbar allahuakbar
kmu kita juga menjadi saksi atas
kuhan ketika yahudi yahudi membantu mer
berkes di tanah airu
mewan darah mkan bumi men di dalam rumah
sakit indonesia ada markas h
كثيرون لم يكن يتصوروا انهم سيعودون الى
التظاهر هنا امام السفاره الامريكيه في
جاكرتا مع بلوغ هذه الحرب يومها المئه
اليوم يعود الاف من الاندونيسيين للتظاهر
امام السفاره الامريكيه مطالبين بوقف
الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه وحملات
التبرعات من اجل الغزيين ومن اجل
الفلسطينيين مستمره وحملات المقاطعه
الاقتصاديه ايضا مستمره هذه المظاهره تاتي
بالتزامن مع مظاهرات اخ
مد اندونسيه اخرى في جزيره جا وغيرها من
الجزر الاندونيسيه وهي تعكس موقفا شعبيا
يتوافق مع الموقف الرسمي قبل ايام تحدثت
وزيره الخارجيه الاندونيسيه منتقده موقف
ما وصفته ببعض دول الشمال الغربيه قائله
بان هذه الدول تعبر عن ازدواجيه المعايير
بالتعامل مع حقوق الانسان الفلسطيني
وتساءلت ان كان الانسان الفلسطيني يختلف
عن غيره من الناس حول العالم من حيث حقوقه
الانسانيه وهو يواجه القتل والتشريد
والتدمير اندونيسيا رفضت التهجير القصري
لسكان غزه كما انها اعلنت قبل يومين
تاييدها لموقفي ومبادر جنوب افريقيا في
محكمه العدل
الدوليه جاسم
الجزيره